we might be drunk
we
might be drunk
as long as we are hanging out you know
we might be drunk raise a glass let's
talk [ __ ] head peeps wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk
we might be drunk
hey hey folks here we are we might be
drunk i'm still hurting from that uh
corpse reviver holy [ __ ] that thing
kicked me in the ass we he said to have
what
won right yeah we we went back down we
had the we had the what three or four
yeah yeah we did a patreon we just kept
going and
i was laying on my couch at about 7 p.m
going i can't go out i had gigs i had to
go out and get chipotle to like stuff
that [ __ ] liquor down i was not doing
well no i was cranky i called the booker
i yelled at him
i did uh i did a spot at the cellar in
that first couple minutes you know in
those first couple minutes you're like
oh i'm drunk yeah
yeah i do know those but i'm not like
i'm not like
i'm not like hammered i'm aware of what
i'm saying but i'm like i'm a step slow
here yes i had a beard even out i was
that guy it feels like you're swimming
with like weights on yes yes i can still
swim but
i'm not gonna win a race no no no even
though you look like michael phelps
you're [ __ ]
from the face up which is not a good
feeling
you never want that compliment yeah
that's true yeah you're way hairier
way
just that
jewish locks floating behind chest air
looks rough in the pool i remember being
like being around my dad in the pool and
it was like coming out to here you know
yeah no one wants to swim next to george
the animal steel that's not a great uh
lap partner by the way all those people
out there you get drunk before a show
you have one to loosen up it's all a
myth the booze slows you down like crazy
it's like saying oh you're going to the
mma fight you get a couple pops did you
no you got to be fresh you got to be
sharp
yeah you know we're better sober
obviously i mean there's there's some
comics who do it like stanhope i feel
like has always done it yeah he's almost
gone over the hump where he's like
normal drunk well when you're a
full-fledged alcoholic yeah you're
probably you don't know how to perform
sober exactly whatever you use so i
guess you can pull it off if you become
a full-on
drunk yeah yeah you gotta but you got it
takes a couple years of hitting your
wife and abandoning your kids and duis
and all that so
you got to really commit to it
did you see those guys in the heyday the
david tells the geraldos like drinking
back there like nick griffin drank all
these guys well i never i wasn't around
were you no but i remember you used to
go to shows at least
yeah i remember went to see tell live in
like 2004 and yeah and he was he did
like a yeager shot on stage wow
that's why
jaeger
yeah
i saw
we've all seen bert i mean bert drinks
you know
it's crazy it's crazy yeah
it's crazy who else he drinks to get the
nerve to drive that's how he drinks
yeah he blows a breathalyzer and it's
like not drunk enough
this car won't start oh my god have you
ever been picked up by someone who has
one of those no i did a gig once it was
forget what club was in the midwest and
uh
the guy they sent me to pick who picked
me up at the airport
he had to blow into it to start the car
because i guess he got a dui which is
like it makes you feel like a real real
high up on the comedy list yeah
the guy you flipped his toyota two
months ago thanks for sending me tiger
woods
jesus christ i'd rather caitlyn jenner
pick me up at the airport for [ __ ]
sake at least you'll hit the guy on the
road not you
well
yeah bruce
caleb it was chaos it was caitlin yeah
it was once you became a woman that was
that was the punch line there you go
that was the whole thing but we uh so
he's
uh picking up we're driving and he'd
have to pull over to blow into it just
to make sure he didn't like start once
he did that whoa that's how little they
trusted him they're like we're gonna
give you a pop quiz every once in a
while you gotta pull over so how does it
work does the car it's just click click
click and then it goes
and then it starts up i guess yeah and
then i remember he got pissed at me
because i was like oh this is hilarious
i'll do like an instagram story uh to
like to promote the gigs i'm like oh
they sent the best ride he was like
please please don't oh my gosh i want
i've been through enough my wife left me
and then i realized i'm like oh he's a
person i'm an [ __ ] yeah well
christopher reeves
god rest his soul he had that machine
that uh wheelchair and he would operate
it with his breath because he couldn't
who's paralyzed so he would like and it
would be damn so imagine if you played a
prank on him you put the breathalyzer
thing up to that you're like i'm sorry
chris you had a champagne [ __ ] earlier
you're not going anywhere
all right what are we drinking tonight
sorry what are we doing today we just
have uh basically a classic paloma the
bar jew with a paloma we got
tequila
grapefruit juice soda water a little
little lime and uh i put a little
rosemary in there just for a little bit
of aromatics this is gorgeous but other
than that very simple little salt rim as
well
you've kicked it up a notch yeah look at
this look at that but it's also very
easy to make at home you know come on so
just i heard the mexicans when they eat
ass they put a little salt on the rim
that's cocaine actually
how did they hit a lime
this looks good that looks delight i
mean you guys you're gonna get laid
tonight baby what is what what is the is
there like a history it's a mexican
drink right the paloma yeah so a lot of
people think that um
uh in the 1860s there was like some huge
hit song called paloma
and they think it was named after that
paloma yeah and uh
but it just started out in like a huge
hotel in uh mexico in cancun i think but
i'm not sure you can't quote me on that
all right that is one of the most
popular uh tequila drinks like in the
world actually besides the margarita
margarita is number one this is this is
garfunkel yeah
i'll forget it right after it's over
this is it's good it tastes almost like
just like kind of not too sweet which i
like i know
it's like a great fruity refreshing
summer drink yeah like the traditional
one uses actually uses like grapefruit
soda
um but i just made it with soda like
grape red grapefruit juice and soda
water just so people can at home can
make it because so grapefruit soda is
kind of a [ __ ] to find so oh really
yeah hurry dose or something do they do
it i don't know if burritos does it but
we could probably find a flavor like
that oh some people in the south use
squirt oh wow damn
david tell joke oh
tried to have a romantic dinner with
candlelight she blew him out
um but that is so good it almost sounds
like uh you know if you're a drunk cop
you're like
paloma
all right i gotta get out of here dip
your waiter this is good man grapefruit
is underrated underrated especially in a
drink it gets a bad rap i feel like
grapefruit is like hip to [ __ ] on
they're like grapefruit
i've seen comics get a punchline without
like grapefruit sucks and you're just
like it's [ __ ] good i hate to say but
one of our favorite comedians but that's
a good bit that's a great bit he tackles
grapefruit with a chunk of this one this
is why gary goldman is great because
he does it for like seven minutes yes
it's not like but i've seen comics do it
like a cop out where they're like oh
like the grapefruit and you're like you
gotta have more than just that yeah but
but goldman has a great take of like
when you have a tumor it's the size of a
grapefruit that's what you compare it to
as a tumor it's so perfect and it he
said it ruins a whole he's got this is
one of the great lines in comedy
uh it ruins the whole fruit salad when
there's a grapefruit he's like it takes
down everyone like a 10th grade pothead
oh wow
oh man
damn he's a great writer that gull
he's a great comic
this is a this is a problem because this
is sneaky i could drink 12 of these
yeah this is good man man the mexicans
do it right they really mexican food is
probably like the easiest food yeah
because i feel like everyone unless you
have some dairy thing but
other than that everyone is on board
with mexican it's got to be the most
popular cuisine in america don't you
think probably like ethnic cuisine yeah
don't you think yeah yeah for sure san
diego that's all they talk about san
antonio that's all they talk about l.a
holy yep holy [ __ ] they're like we have
mexican food we have it everywhere
but ours is better look it's it is
better yeah l.a i i i it pains me to
give anything to la but we got to play
it fair they've got better mexican food
you have a burrito in san diego it as
the kids say it hits different you know
it's got like some weird green sauce in
there and they put the lime and the
radish it's [ __ ] great the radish is
underrated you ever throw a little
butter on a radish
dude that's
that's a [ __ ] good move butter on a
radish i'm telling you the french man
wait a minute you just take a full
radish you slice it you put a little
butter on it i've never heard of
something let's talk about can you look
that up to tell me i'm not crazy i think
i saw bourdain do that i've been doing
that ever since
that's a that's a hot move man the
radish with butter you know bourdain ate
ass
i mean imagine if he didn't eat a
woman's ass she'd be like are you
kidding me i watched you eat like a
snake's heart
yeah but you go the snakes are tasted
good
yeah
wow radish and sweet butter i'm telling
you it's pretty good oh kosher i didn't
know this was some kind of a hebrew
thing i'm not trying to i'm not trying
to sneak this one in this is for every i
think there's a french thing
radishes with butter and salt there you
go it's pretty good sounds like a light
nice light lunch it's nice yeah nice
little snack mexicans also great beer by
the way i love a modelo i love a dos
equis negro modelo do you go especially
oh especially i go negro oh
easy
[Laughter]
i said negro yeah
yeah yeah i go especially i like it a
little lighter and then the soul is
great i mean even a tecate is solid
picante is a good cheap beer yeah that's
like the mexican pbr exactly and it's
way better it's way better pbr sucks it
sucks i see people i saw someone with
one of my shows drinking a pbr and i
said what do you really want it's on me
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's a great move the on me is big
you can afford it
that's nice the pbr is like i mean even
milwaukee's best beats the [ __ ] out of
pbr i agree i agree and i would drink 22
ounces of those [ __ ] one after one in
brooklyn just because it was so cheap i
would drink i used to drink so many 40s
old english cole 45 they were just cheap
and they and they were like it was kind
of fun to have a 40 because
this is going to sound really pathetic
but like it felt satisfying to finish
one it did yeah that last sip you're
like i did it it's the worst kind of
accomplishment
it's true but uh it was so thick that
malt liquor and it got you real [ __ ]
up did you ever do edward 40 hands
oh you have to strap them both
i never did that but i mean we got
[ __ ] up i've seen people do that we
did it i i'm the only thing i'm good at
is i have a big bladder because a bed
wedding and my dad made me not pissed
all day because he's a [ __ ] but uh
i i could i could drink two of them and
not pee and my friend's like this is
unbelievable
it was the best moment of my life that
is pretty impressive i pee non-stop i'm
like a [ __ ] 80 i don't know how it's
going to get worse oh my god you got a
bladder of a grapefruit
[Laughter]
it's horrible man i wake up literally
every two hours i feel like what yeah i
wake up a lot oh no i'm also just i'm
just an irritable human being i'll be
like my neck will hurt i'll piss i'll
just wake up early i'll just like my
girlfriend will just wake up and she'll
be like you're just awake i'm like yeah
yeah i have that too but just because of
mental [ __ ] but the two-hour urine i
mean you're ruining your whole sleep
cycle it's killing me
damn i feel bad
yeah i hate to say but you could stretch
it
yeah yeah i mean just hold it in just
hold it and it's uncomfortable but like
start holding it then you go alright i
made it for 20 minutes i'll go pee now
next day i made it for 30. and then
before you know it you you're gonna be
good damn it's crazy that you can work
[ __ ] like that out it's crazy you can
stretch like everything
yeah i mean you can it's literal
stretching like if we do this every day
we could do a split
but it's just a pain about that you
think we do a split well i mean you see
guys doing it
i don't think they're us
probably not they're like those are like
gymnast type dudes yeah but everybody
starts somewhere i don't know
how flexible are you flexible no i'm
stiff as a board like my girlfriend will
sometimes [ __ ] with me and like try to
put my legs over my head
and uh like i said joke and i'm like it
hurts she's like that's crazy if i was
as unflexible as you we couldn't bang do
you ever uh
you know
she likes the leg up throw it around
she's like a gumby and uh or stretch
armstrong for the the younger kids
who's the new bendy guy i don't even
know anything they're a new baby
armstrong
dude
that toy was awesome for about uh 20
minutes
that's the toys we played with we're
like look his arm stretched like how
[ __ ] how [ __ ] primitive was [ __ ]
before video games that's a good i mean
they were video games but like not
really not great yeah stretcher
armstrong was huge and my friend cut him
open and ate the [ __ ] inside i think he
had to go to the hospital
when that's armstrong he's been pulled
out like that he looks like he's in like
a [ __ ] uh dominatrix video
yeah it's a torture thing torture porn
that was a torture device the stretch
thing that's true that's crazy that some
guy made those like the the coffin with
the spikes in it or the stretchy apart
thing
some guy had to design those look at
that that was a part of history yeah
someone's making that
that's a pretty bad dude right there now
we do this on twitter you know it's all
we're all the same like we act like
these are horrible people but we all we
have all those genes and
you know the same wiring twitter is just
is i'm looking less and less it's just
madness good for you it's it's evil are
you on there a lot i try to write a joke
a day and have a little exercise and
then people were like why aren't you why
are you silent about this and i'm like
silent we could do that all day like why
aren't you talking about elderly abuse
you know like do you hate the old
governor
yeah what that was silent oh my god i've
noticed you haven't spoken up about the
the
whatever protest i'm like i didn't know
about it yeah what about the taliban
should we where's your thing about that
you know i know you want to scroll
through their [ __ ] well that's the new
thing now i have a bit now about this
it's hitting about how like you know
everyone's like you know i saw a guy in
a shirt that said [ __ ] racism and i'm
like problem solved you did it like
that's what they think they're doing in
their head so i have a whole thing i'm
gonna roll uh i'm gonna start rolling
into parties in a shirt that just says
against baby rape nah and they're just
like why are you wearing that i'd be
like are you for baby rape you know you
just spin it on them it really is so
dumb the [ __ ] that
because that's what twitter is it's like
these people who are like trying to
expose you it's like you have [ __ ]
chinks in your armor too right easy
[Laughter]
they're gonna come after me for that one
right there they're like what you said
of course they got the chicks and uh we
all got the armor but it's it's so true
it's like
it's always the opposite like i feel
like things are better now than they've
ever been
well maybe not with the new abortion law
that ain't good that ain't good you know
it's bad when you have to drive to
oklahoma to take care of business
let's go to the progressive part of this
area tweet it oh really that's good
but i'm sure that's been said and you're
talking to the abortion king i got a
punch card here i'm
one more and i get a freebie yeah yeah i
got a free sub
but uh no i just i'm just saying we
we're we're more progressive than we've
ever been gay marriage is like a joke
like oh if you're against that you're
weird now whereas you know obama clinton
hillary we're all like oh gay marriage
is crazy you know it all changes
obviously you know but we had split
water fountains blah blah blah but i
feel like people are doubling down more
on being angry about stuff and yet they
were they seemed less angry before and i
think it's always kind of the opposite
you know when a supermodel is in the
mirror like i'm so fat i'm so fat you're
like you're not fat but the fat lady's
going i'm beautiful i'm beautiful you're
like no no you're fat she's not fat but
you think you're fat and you think
you're beautiful
and it's kind of the same with the
racial stuff it's like we're [ __ ]
they're killing us in the streets and
you're like
no they used to do that now if they do
that they'll get arrested
yeah no no no i know what you're saying
man i mean i'm going i'm going extremes
no you're making an interesting point i
think because
we twitter is interesting because so
much of news is broken on twitter now
like we will find out a celebrity died
on twitter we will find out you know
i found out i found the abortion thing
on twitter so did i i mean so it's you
find this stuff out i woke up look the
twitter was like oh [ __ ] you know so i
get that outrageous currency but also
like you guys you got to be outraged at
stuff like that well sure sure yeah
that's a that's a new one that's a big
one that's that one is anything moving
back i mean that's the opposite of
progress that's going backwards right
you know agreed agreed yeah and you
think
i think that it's a texas dick swinging
move like
a lot of [ __ ] is going this way well
[ __ ] you we're gonna go backwards you
know it's almost like we're gonna
compensate for your well look at the
governor you know i mean yeah wheelchair
he should have been aboard
well
they sorry this is not a this is not a
political podcast if you haven't noticed
yeah he got covered by the way i know
andy had the booster apparently
imagine like telling people not to wear
masks while you go get a booster like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] like you're you're in your
little safe space and there and you're
letting people die yeah yeah and
booster just sounds so
[ __ ] i need the booster it sounds like
a booster seat oh he's a shitty
character in jingle all the way i've
never seen it you've never seen jingle
all the way no no the best bad christmas
movie ever is that sinbad and
schwarzenegger wow what a combo and phil
hartman what
and rita wilson good catch yeah she's
fun it's that's booster the pink guy
from
you know who plays him curtis armstrong
from revenge of the nerds booger
oh i love that guy i love that guy he's
good he's great but uh jewish
[Laughter]
and oh dude it's classic
it's just a bad it's a good bad movie
all right all right i love a christmas
movie it's fun man yeah it's it's not
good but dude phil hartman yeah yeah is
that guy ever not great i grew up on
sinbad i love cinnamon's incredible yeah
schwarzenegger is a is a great just
great
presence on stage he's so hollywood he's
such a leading man
i'm in
damn dude yeah it's a pretty it's a
pretty bad movie but i enjoy it now what
range we have i say it every week we
went from killing uh
babies to to sinbad
hell yeah it's uh it's weird man you
know that uh
just as tough in texas man i definitely
it is a weird time that is i feel like a
lot of female comedians who moved to
texas are like well i'm heading back
head back to l.a i'm going to raise an
open micros baby
[ __ ] this [ __ ] ah
yeah that that seems like a nightmare
that is bad
damn yeah but hey you know right now the
taliban's like hey that was a good move
there texas
good on ya
now you're getting the idea
we're still not that bad i'm using the
taliban as our uh barometer that's a
tough bar yeah we're not as bad as the
tally no no no we're not we're not
we still have uh
females driving and having opinions yeah
yeah that's uh they killed a community
too many some would say
[Laughter]
you look at twitter that's true uh no uh
who killed a community oh yeah the
taliban killed a comedian tortured him
too i saw that awful awful jesus christ
from tock videos yeah unbelievable
horrible
that [ __ ] hits close to home yeah was he
[ __ ] on the country kind of stuff i
don't i don't know what his jokes were i
don't know what type of comedy he was
but just seeing that you're like well
that's uh
that ain't good that ain't good i mean
half of people's acts in america
[ __ ] on biden [ __ ] on trump
yeah that was that's like a big part of
our our the american ways i don't know
what the av game comedy scene is like i
cannot imagine it's booming
no no we have trans comics here for
christ's sake yeah oh yeah wow
comic beaten
hey
[Music]
oh thought that was a joke uh oh okay
okay it was
yeah this is terrible damn
yeah [ __ ] i mean i will say that man
america has got its problems that's
horrible with texas but uh
we do have a lot to be grateful for sure
i mean there is a reason the afghanis
are coming here
they're fleeing to here right that says
something
and then they'll come and be like never
mind
no you know who's got the best abortion
joke is you remember that louis ck bit
where he's like uh
he's like yeah i think abortion is
murdering a baby but i think a woman
should be allowed to murder her baby
he goes you're allowed to murder someone
if they break into your house
that's great that's a brilliant abortion
joke and it's so he's just saying facts
yeah it's comedy gold yeah because
you're like oh [ __ ] those are the best
jokes where it's almost like you ever
see like magic johnson make a pass and
he doesn't pass to the player he like
passes to the area and the player goes
to the ball those are like the best
jokes where we have to like go to the
thing well like they're ready
that's so i love i love jokes like that
man i do too yeah there's so many of
those out there that they're just
sitting there and yet they're the
hardest to see like yeah like norm
mcdonald's joke about he's like people
are scared of korea korea he's like
my dad died of a heart attack that's
inside you he's like i'm scared of my
heart you know like it kills you from
the inside i'm not worried about korea
i'm worried about this guy oh that's
it's like in you i mean it's such a
great point that's fears you have when
you get older and like also like man i
had like i thought i was having an
allergic reaction a hotel room a couple
weeks ago and that feeling while your
neck it was just really bad allergies i
sound so [ __ ] jewish right now oh my
god i'm like a stereotype but i almost
died from allergies guys but i know but
i was like closing up to the point where
i was like oh this sucks
and uh
i was like man you just think about
maybe dying in a hotel room and you're
like that's rough
oh especially if it's not a great hotel
yeah
you [ __ ] died in the la kinta
stinks what what gig was it where were
you i was in portland ah portland yeah
damn yeah like geraldo died in jersey i
know they're gonna hilt
but yeah
one of the one of the best ever
yeah it's a good one
no no yeah geraldo one of the best
he really was one of the best and uh
yeah [ __ ]
i know
i wonder where mitch hedberg died give
that a goog
because he was a heroin addict
apparently he was shooting up the leg he
said when you lifted the leg up it was
just purple like civil war
gang grain type [ __ ] exactly awful was
he also new jersey
damn geez i was i'm there this weekend
[ __ ] you'll die too yeah
i'll just die on stage
hotel room in
westminster hotel john panetta died in
hotel him too a lot of comedians die in
hotel rooms
man i don't want to speak ill of the
dead but uh i did a gig i'm not going to
say where and i had the crazy eccentric
limo driver he's like oh he's got his
tie loose he's got wacky hair he's like
he's driving with a foot on the dash you
know he's got his own car it's got the
fuzzy dice it's all decked out he's like
i've been picking up comics since 1979
i've had everybody steve martin prior
you name it and he said he had panette
and he's like panette was wild he's like
everybody talks about kinnison and dice
and pry or ken i mean pinette he was
like make you get get off the airport go
right to a liquor store two two fifths
of tequila then he had his own [ __ ] you
get hookers all that it was like holy
[ __ ] pinette he was like this cute fat
guy my mom liked him every mom loved
putting that he was huge in the midwest
he was a great guy i mean killer comedy
such a nice guy john panetta if you
haven't looked him up for the folks at
home and yeah beast for sure
damn yeah i had no idea he was like a
booze bag and a party animal it's hard
to do what we do and not drink
it is hard to like
come down after a set and not
come to it like it's such an abrupt
change of pace it really is because you
do feel like incredible up there you
feel so good yeah and then you come off
and you're like oh yeah that's it
i know just over just boom so like sex
you're it's over you know it's over you
come right you're glad it's over you're
not glad the set's over that's true yeah
unless it's horrible
yeah
yeah and then you go back and here's the
here's the irony and or the catch 22 or
whatever it is you go back to the green
room and you're in there it's quiet you
maybe got the opener maybe the host the
waitress comes in you need anything and
it's completely somber and weird you
were just riffing rapping applause hoot
and holler getting heckled handling
lights in your face to
thank you
green room quiet
there's your uh you know your your fish
sticks with the cigarette butt in it the
napkin wrapped up there's your beer and
you're like all right
that's it but
you don't want anything else really like
what do you do if an audience member
comes in you're like ah
you know like it's a weird thing of like
it's weirdly quiet but you also don't
want
to do stuff well you're getting those
laughs and you kind of mistake that
laughter as a as a kind of love at least
in that moment yes and then you go to
nothing so it's almost like you've been
consuming it's like a sugar high and
coming down
yeah because you're getting like fake
love in a way right
you know and it's like they're enjoying
you so much that that killing laughter
you're like oh i feel like they love me
right now and then you get off and
you're just like oh that's not real love
that's just it's temporary yeah but so
then you kind of come to it's like a
sugar crash
that's a great way to put it it's a
sugar crash but you could do the meet
and greet
uh and get more love but the meet and
greet is hard
oh my god it's exhausting and i hate to
say it because there's people out there
going oh he's coming to tampa i'm gonna
say hello and it'll be great but you're
like they don't know the the mental [ __ ]
we're going through of like it's another
show it's another show
this on stage is easier because you just
kind of like find
i used to be so nervous on stage and now
it's kind of like yeah i kind of know
what i'm going to say and like if
something misses and i'll work on it
it's not like
the jokes don't have the same stakes
that they used to have you know what
what do you mean i mean
i think i used to just react to bombing
oh i i still hate bombing but i think
now when a joke misses i'm like all
right i'll either fix it or i'll drop it
and that but you your first hour of
jokes you work so hard on i mean oh yeah
you work
for years on them and then you get to a
place where you're like you're just not
as attached to the jokes
right that's why i think the bombs when
you're younger just hurt more because
you're like well i know that i worked so
long on that now when you bomb now
you're like all right well maybe that
joke wasn't that good yet yeah it's a
good point yeah you're right i i think
we're more realistic
yeah we're less attached less emotional
it's kind of like your first girlfriend
yeah she you she dumps you and you're
like oh my god i'm gonna never i'm gay
now i'll never go back and then you
start banging a couple ladies and then
some gal dumps you're like all right
i'll meet somebody else yeah it's kind
of like that with comedy but maybe we do
need a little to go back to that that
young young love maybe we need a little
stretch armstrong uh you know
torture torture yeah get spanked a
little bit yeah cry
yeah exactly i don't know man
yeah it's tough it's tough but
you know still love it still out there
still grinding we just want to create
good [ __ ] that's really what it all
comes down to
you know and and i think like i heard i
always hear bill burr he's kind of like
my
go-to to listen to sure and he always
says
sometimes i'll think i did a hot show at
some theater they loved me and then my
opener's going to an open mic
he's like oh why would i do that and
then he's like i'll go because i don't
want to go and it'll shake me up like
man these people were just blowing me at
the theater
these guys don't really care and i gotta
i gotta wake him up and i gotta figure
it out and it kicks that thing inside
you any gig you're scared to do might be
good for you and that goes for
everything in life
yeah the harder thing to do is is
sometimes you're like oh this is
necessary it's easier it is easier to
kill on a sold-out crowd of people that
came to see you but when you're doing
those little shitty gigs
and you're going up with comics that are
hungry as hell and they're not there for
you yep
you're kind of on a level playing field
it's kind of yeah good for you that's
one thing cool about the comedy store in
la and well we're getting deep into
comedy but like
he would have to follow dalia or guys
like that at the height of their
whatever and like these are high-energy
cool young sexy guys or gals and eliza
schlesinger and joey diaz like all these
so like sure you're joe blow the cool
guy comic big guy big name legend but
it's still like this is a young crowd
that was a young comic they don't give a
[ __ ] about my old ass and my kids and my
wife
they want to hear [ __ ] party jokes or
fun jokes and you gotta make it work
yeah levels it kind of hey we're back to
i ain't
you know john john johnson the legend
here i'm
following this guy who's famous and and
hot right now john johnson dude that guy
used to he used to do a lot of blow and
strippers you ever hear stories about
that guy yeah i couldn't think of a
cooler name
no dude you know i i do get tired
sometimes i feel burnt out like just
trying to like take care of myself now
or you know we do the road every week so
you come back i used to do so many club
spots in the city like i realized those
nights of me doing four new york spots a
night are kind of over yeah like i'll do
a couple in a night but i'm i'm not
going to brooklyn to do
a show
that pays nothing that might suck yeah
no i get that because i'm like i'm on
the road i'm too tired i'm just like i'm
all the flights i mean [ __ ] all the
delays and then
you
do you know five or six hours of shows
in a weekend and then you're gonna come
back for like a ten minutes that's just
it doesn't make sense no you got to take
care of yourself so you're good for
those shows that's true you're right no
you're right and and what are you going
to get out of that show well you don't
do those shows sometimes but like i
don't prioritize them like that
we were so conditioned to say yes to
everything because we were abused for so
long that we get to we get to a place
where we say yes and [ __ ] when we were
like wait did i just say yes to this
[ __ ] i know i had that last night what
did what was it i did a show you ever
heard of breezy point
it's a neighborhood in queens give this
a look up there sloppy crazy point it's
a it's a neighborhood i feel like i'm
giving it away but it's on the map it's
a neighborhood in queens i kept calling
it long island i'm sure they hated me i
did a bar it's on the beach
look at that look at that
what are you thinking doing this this
far out well i said yes to it six months
ago
look at that this i did that last night
how long did it take to get there it
only took about an hour and a half to
get there by car
but we just cut straight through
brooklyn do they pay you well it paid
well
but it is a [ __ ] like
rootin tootin
bar show at a beach house on the beach
wow like uh
crazy
fun
beach party vibes
and this place is crazy it's like kind
of walled off and they it's it's like
irish italian firemen
cool cool people but just like
we keep this neighbor it was like the
50s over there there's like a little ice
cream shop and and like not a
scratch of trash no uh [ __ ] graffiti
i was like i can't believe i'm queens
you know because queens you think of
like astoria and some no i felt like the
beginning of like a forensic files like
yeah a small beach town turned upside
down exactly exactly but i didn't even
know this place existed and it was wild
is it pretty it looks pretty beautiful
but it feels like you're in destin
florida or malibu or something it's just
it's
clean that looks beautiful yeah it's
crazy so uh it was just a fun show but
it was rowdy and i was scared out of my
mind you know what this looks like that
little uh
runway on the beach right there it looks
like the episode where jerry he promises
he won't say hello to that woman yes
exactly and then he just starts running
yeah that might have been shot there no
that was probably in l.a but it's just
beautiful town like you feel like you're
in florida or something it's so beachy
and uh the crowd was good crowd was
great but they were rowdy and they would
yell at you and they would heckle and
they were they're in flip-flops and
shorts and they're all tan and holding a
coconut drink going like talk about the
taliban or whatever taliban everyone
wants jokes with that i opened by going
i just got back from kabul so this is a
good gig they're like
you know and then i did as a seller
later and they were like jesus christ
but it was fun cause it was like it felt
like i was on the road for one night and
came back those are fun those are fun
listen do you bring someone with you
well they brought me like the the people
drove me out there and they all opened
and they knew everybody like this guy
looks like he went to sacred heart am i
right they're like oh [ __ ] they knew all
the local references for the the
catholic high schools and everything so
i had to follow like some local acts
which was tough but uh they were great
big t the whole gang and uh you know the
guy the guy's mom is there and
everything it was like real
local [ __ ]
uh but i was scared to go on i was like
[ __ ] this is this is nerve-wracking here
it's good to feel nervous like it is it
is
and then you come up with stuff on the
fly because your brain is in this fight
or flight like i'm about to get my ass
kicked by these
you know beachcombers
but they were great they were great they
were nice and they hate the city like
[ __ ] the city we live in the city
technically but [ __ ] going in there it's
dirty it's dangerous they've kind of
built this their own little little
little paradise out there yeah i don't
know man i'm i'm pro city but i i i new
york's getting hard to defend it is it's
so expensive still there's
it's just madness i the the lack of taxi
cabs in the city right now is new york
is such a taxi cab city it's it bums me
out i'm watching old movies and they
just like get a cab like that and you're
like that's the pace of new york yeah
not to be like oh coming in seven
minutes that's not new york uh that's a
great point yeah that's so true it's uh
it's a new york minute yeah now it's an
uber minute yeah which is about six
minutes if we're being honest dude uber
i tried getting an uber on the road the
midwest oh it's like coming in like 23
minutes and you're like are you [ __ ]
kidding me yeah i schedule them
you schedule them yeah that
was one of my rigs like if i'm going to
bed at 4 00 a.m and i need to pick up at
9 00 a.m i schedule that thing for for i
gotta do that i forgot about that we
drank on this podcast so i forget a lot
tell me about it it's paloma that's
pretty good hitting the spot dude i will
yeah i i was waiting for like 23 minutes
or something for an uber it's [ __ ]
crazy
it's crazy i know if i can make a woman
come in less than the time in uber
then maybe you guys got to step it up
yeah i'll tell you i'm getting i've been
with my gal so long i'm getting really
good at like
the [ __ ] stuff how are you it's amazing
are you good in general do you think
you're just good on her her yeah i would
say it's gonna it's amazing how horrible
i i learned i was it's like therapy
where you had to go okay i'm bad i need
to fix this i have an ego too so it took
me a minute when i you know when i was i
was like you're not doing it right a bit
i think i know what i'm doing you don't
know where the [ __ ] is i'm like on her
shoulder yeah
but uh that [ __ ] is a goddamn
enigma
yeah because it's so small
it's so small that like uh
it's so hard to feel but then you can't
feel too much because it's sensitive so
then you're she's like ah that hurts and
you're like god damn it i know go easy
on us ladies with the [ __ ] the [ __ ] hate
cause we're we're trying well it's tough
cause sometimes they're like harder
harder than like i'm like ah you're like
i'm sorry [ __ ] exactly
you gotta deal with one giant [ __ ] with
a hole in it and stuff comes out of it
when it's over and it's very it's very
simple the penis is much easier to work
oh yeah
so bear with us and then like they like
the fingering when you hit the top part
so you're like okay you got to tell me
that how do i know that you know like we
don't know what you're feeling so you
got to you got to be vocal yeah i a
little guidance why not yeah
i i know it's not hot to be like here
here here i understand like giving
directions while you're doing it might
take you out of the mood but a little
just give us a little and you can say it
how like softer oh harder harder or
whatever you don't make it hot i think
they feel weird sometimes to just like
say what they need i agree i i can't say
what i need either on on like a
emotional level oh really oh i tell you
exactly what i need i feel like
i'm like in the ass
harder
yeah
i don't know how you do it but uh
yeah i i don't know how she gets the
cucumber out
but tongs tongues
yeah
but the thing is
you can't have it both ways ladies if
you're not gonna guide we're not gonna
get you there probably so
you're just willing oh my god to to get
you there it's not gonna happen geez
what it's like breezy point i need a
little help yeah exactly a little help
yes yeah throw me a bone here we might
be drunk is brought to you by my bookie
football's back baby oh my giants man i
can't wait you're a saints guy hell yeah
who dat
you like easy money thanks to my bookie
and their lock of the season if either
the team scores in the nfl season opener
you win if you don't know how a game has
ended 0-0 since world war ii so this is
a short bet head to my bookie.ag select
lock of the season and if any team
scores between the dallas cowboys and
the tampa bay bucks you win
the best bet you can make is one you
can't lose my bookie is also hosting
several exclusive contests including
their 100 000 super contest the best
part it only cost 10 bucks to enter
there's big money on the line this
season so don't wait to get in the game
join now mark tell him how to do it hell
yeah i just made a couple clams on that
jake paul fight thank you my bookie oh
you bet on him oh yeah
and uh nobody believed in me
head to mybookie.a.g
today and use our promo code drunk and
instantly double your first deposit
that's double your funds to double your
winnings again that's promo code drunk
to receive double your first deposit and
get started with my bookie today bet
anything anytime
anywhere with my
bookie sheath underwear folks wearing it
right now look at that i'm wearing it
too look at that hey there you go we
gave ourselves a melvin that's what they
call in the front melvin i haven't said
that word in 20 years a [ __ ] nerd
name it's a great never name your kid
melvin no bad name bad that's a rough
one that kid's good if that kid doesn't
get the [ __ ] kicked out of him then he
has just become such he's surpassed
expectation oh yeah keeps your balls off
your leg there's two pouches one for
your dong one for your sack
keep the ammo separate from the gun it's
super supportive they look good they
feel good they're like stretchy and
silky at the same time the lady likes
them she's like you look great in that
look at these these are camo like weird
cameras dude i have those at home too i
would never buy these but when i put
them on i feel cool as hell your dick
was in the gulf war i love it yeah i got
a sandy hook or no wait sandy dick [ __ ]
hook what the [ __ ] this is a plug man
i'm sorry this guy was in the iraq war
by the way this guy's a badass oh yeah
he's a veteran supporter veteran this
guy's a a great he's a great dude yeah
he's a veteran he loves comics which is
why he's on this podcast uh
go to sheath underwear dot com in order
with promo code drunk to get 20 off your
first order and sheath underwears 100
back money back guarantee that sheath
underwear dot com promo code drunk get
sheath underwear and let them support
your balls the salt rim is [ __ ] nice
it's very nice the salt rim is always
pleasant
so what's good about the bar jew i
watched him in here tearing open salt
packets i was like what are you doing
he's like i couldn't find any salt i'm
like man this guy's good damn that's
like some man versus wild [ __ ] in the
bar i love it you know i'll tell you i
love a good little chili salt rim too
you have a chili salt room oh
a little spicy i have had that it's the
the redder it's like a reddish spicy
butthole buddy i love it yeah you ever
ever gone downtown and felt a uh
a tingle
i i've never really found a woman who's
into it
no no i'm saying you've ever licked the
thing where you're like that oh that
wasn't that yeah that tasted like i'm
not sure i don't think so you're a lucky
man yeah you're not into that huh well
no i'm just saying like i've licked a
butt before and i'm like why did i why
is my tongue burning
why is my tongue hurt
that's what i'm saying and why do i have
a fever of 103.
what's going on yeah why don't i need to
chug milk right now am i on a hot one
what's going on here
yeah
so
that's the next step in hot ones instead
of wings shaq is gonna eat ass
that's the next hot one that's where
it's gonna go i mean
we have to keep upping it you know yeah
ah shaq is gonna eat ass that's
hilarious it's just there's just a woman
bending over and an interview happening
he's like all right
jack's like oh [ __ ] he's like yeah
that's a tough one that's that's a bad
that's a spicy ass
the dominican ass yeah they like
describe it it's got a hint of uh
chocolate and chili yeah
hot ones
what a great idea for a show i know that
guy's killing it it's like really the
simplest idea it's like oh yeah you want
apparently he gives great interview
questions too i haven't seen it but like
i hear it's great but then i just look
at him like that's perv it's simple is
good it really is but it's simple and
original yeah it's hard to do most
simple things have been done but he
found some wings wings and you get
vulnerable you get these big actors
vulnerable like dj khaled who sucks and
he's talentless but he's like
oh [ __ ] i'm hurting here and you're like
well i've never seen you he won't do
this no he won't do the spin-off show
that we've created oh no he's he's a
bummer yeah another one of you you stink
we'll get you out of here let's get
another celebrity but
yeah yeah just like seeing those kind of
people men and women these giant
celebrity millionaires like oh [ __ ] i'm
hurting here it's fun
with the questions you get the best of
both
yeah he uh
it's a great idea
because it's it that he must regret it
the way we kind of feel it every once in
a while in this show where he's like
[ __ ] uh eating wings at a certain
point yeah i bet the other day we were
like [ __ ] i don't not feel like eating
spicy wings today i never thought about
that that's a great point because we are
you know
we're feeling it some days oh there's
some days when we drink on the road and
i'm just like oh [ __ ] all right we got a
drink for this podcast i know i know
it's tough but also we are destroying
our brains that's true
which is like the only thing we need
you're welcome you're welcome yeah he's
destroying maybe a taste bud or you know
having a burning sensation maybe some
[ __ ] burning butt for sure yeah i
mean i mean i have a burning butt from
this stuff oh my god i make here's my i
want it all that's my problem i got you
know what i did yesterday we we
pre-recorded we're doing two because i'm
out of town mark's out of town but like
we
so we did the episode yesterday we had a
bunch of those drinks
i had a ton of coffee that day to just
make it through the day i ate spicy thai
for dinner
wash it down with some
candy what kind of candy gummy bears ah
you're a child and and i had a like a
peanut butter cup too
we were watching watching tv and
holy [ __ ] and then i had the nerve to be
sitting in the toilet this morning like
why
as if i didn't know don't forget that
donut oh my god we have donuts
oh god
bacon don't oh i deserve it yeah yeah i
deserve to be in pain every now and then
throw in a nectarine or something just
keep them in the house throw them on top
of the fridge just just to surprise my
body yeah just like thank god your body
gets a glass of water to banana it's
like thank you
it's funny you see porn of a guy getting
like whipped and tortured you're like
who would put their body through this
and i'm like oh yeah i do what i do is
worse probably yeah you do it on the
inside yeah that's funny i'm a [ __ ]
idiot
but candy and spicy ties amazing at
least there's some vegetables in there i
love thai food is like if we're going
like takeout in new york i don't think i
don't think you're top time number one
that's probably my go-to same here i
come back from the road i go hey lady
we're going out to dinner what do you
want she goes how about ty i said yeah i
can get thai every time what's your thai
order i go
well see i go to this one place called
galanga shout out but they got this they
got a thing called little garden is that
is that a normal thing little garden
that's what they call on the menu but
it's just basically like happy ending is
that normal up there
what is a little garbage it's galanga uh
it's just vegetables you pick your you
get your chicken your beef or your pork
you pick or shrimp and i get the chicken
and uh
what's in it there oh you might be you
might have gone down a wormhole here
sister but uh
either way was it noodles or like what
is this rice so they give you the side
of rice they always put in a cone shape
which i appreciate love a cone love a
cone it goes a long way and
you just dump it right on the veggies
and the sauce and i mix it in and it's
delightful what's in that give me the
description there i can't read that it's
too small oh walk stirred broccoli
cauliflower carrot string bean bok choy
baby corn and a light soya sauce with
jasmine rice see i don't know what any
of that is
bok choy is cabbage you know what that
is okay but i don't know what soya is
but
it's soy sauce i think it's probably a
typo is that a
no they don't have typos and thai yeah
oh oh it is
that is soya sauce all right
fermented soybeans soya beans
all right so it's basically like a rice
with some veggies and a meat
what do you do i go noodles man i get
those drunken noodles man oh i love
drumming that's my go-to
that's a great order i just feel guilty
about that because that's a lot of
noodle you're you're in you're inhaling
uh a big amount of pasta am i yeah but i
mean hey i'm with you i do it too that's
that's my favorite i do uh drunken
noodles
and
it's still good though it's hacked for a
reason attack pads use a nice little
order that's a great one that's my
number two patch you i go drunken
noodles pads to you and then pad thai
for noodles yeah yeah i'll [ __ ] with
some curry oh yeah i always saw anthony
bourdain at these asian the weird truck
stops with like eight guys and they're
at like a picnic table and he always had
this amazing looking
thai food or chinese food whatever the
[ __ ] it was and he had a beer with him
and i was like man that looks good made
food look so good yeah dude that whole
intro he's in the sunglasses the whole
time he's a cool dude i know he never
faked it he never like he never did all
got all hostie
yeah here we are folks uh it's good to
be here in thailand he was just like
i'm hungover we're in thailand we're
gonna we're gonna get a haircut and a
massage and then go eat and you're like
this guy's living the best apparently
not
but uh
like it didn't end well i'm saying yeah
no it's just tough when a guy like that
does it
because he's the coolest he had the best
life but then everyone said the best
life and you're like that was a tough
life you're on the road all the time you
don't get to see your kid for sure you
have to turn it on like you're on that's
a lot of shoot like you watch how many
episodes he does per season you're like
that's a lot of travel and shooting oh
really i mean think about those are
hour-long episodes dude
wow that's true those are long
shoot days you got to be on because
think about how much they probably don't
even use yeah
why doesn't that girlfriend of his get
more more flack
which i feel like she's a big reason he
pulled the trigger well we don't know
that
that's not fair to put on her i mean but
she doesn't seem like a great person
either i mean she had a 14 year old on
the side she was cheating 14 yeah he
wasn't 14. look at him he was a younger
guy was he really 14 he was yeah i think
she was grooming really yeah yeah
it's weird that grooming can be either
great or horrible i know that isn't that
weird you're either like you're either
like oh just make sure my side burns
you're intact or you're [ __ ] a 14
year old
why why are those the only two ways
that's it yeah it's either like oh hell
his mustaches
perfect yeah yeah like i send my dog and
i get groomed
and then it's or it's you getting a 15
year old ready to get plowed it ain't
good that ain't good
i had a thought the other day about how
jump roping is either done by the
toughest guy on the planet or the most
innocent kid it's like a 10 year old or
a [ __ ]
murderer
interesting yeah there's not much in
between it's not like a 40 year old guy
jump roping really
that's true yeah it's either someone
who's going to kill a kid or it's that
kid
yeah maybe he got it from the kitty
kills aha that's not bad
can i use that use it all right what uh
yeah is that is that legit matt is was
she was he 14 was she grooming a guy
i know she she had a thing about against
weinstein she was one of those she
called him out publicly
but i also heard her but also apparently
you know she they were in an open
relationship but she was like you know
but then she was you know being public
with other guys which is it's not how
you do it
yeah yeah that's not very classy i mean
if you look if you're adults and you
consent to an open relationship
that's your choice for me i think that's
like an odd choice personally yeah but
also
uh
that's we and but you know but then she
was not very discreet i guess
no no no no
i don't trust her
yeah i don't either i don't know why but
i don't yeah
either way
[Music]
neither here nor there groomed this
innocent boy since six years old
wow is this but is this confirmed
because if we do
right right
oh boy this is getting ugly this is
getting juicy let's get back to the
taliban this is getting too uh
hairy here
um
harry styles he would be harry if it was
groomed
yes
here here uh you got a bit
or a peeve i got a beef please i don't
know if we've read this on a patreon or
whatever but i was thinking about this
we've done so many but by the way sign
up for our patreon patreon.com we might
be drunk pod email us questions peeves
uh
[ __ ] jokes drinks anything that we
might be drunk pod at gmail.com
if you've got packages for us send them
to gotham studios on 38th street oh yeah
we got we opened them on the on the
patreons they've been a ton of fun we
video them too got a good little thing
going here um yeah you could have your
[ __ ] on the wall in the studio don't
forget yeah we're dying to replace this
one right here so whatever the hell yeah
see the mennonites i don't know if
they're that yeah
we had a good danger if it went over
there why don't we just switch these two
that's better right yeah we got a lot of
rodney in here
i'll tell you i tell ya this is this is
here to stay yeah prior the the tony
with the horse the big three is here to
stay for sure we could dump that one
though too
you know the horse's name again
pile my oh my classic all right here's a
peeve people who say no pressure
when there should be no pressure
no you get a text like hey no pressure
but uh will you uh watch my house for
three weeks and you're like why would i
why would there be pressure in that
uh-huh it's a big ask sometimes people
say that when it's like a big ask i i
would argue there is pressure
what do you mean like no pressure
can you watch my house you're like jesus
christ that's what the point i'm making
is like ah you're [ __ ] there this is
like a high pressure ask i'm saying oh
oh so there is pressure
well yeah there shouldn't be pressure
because it's like yeah you shouldn't be
asking this even right it's it's two
that's right i misspoke yeah yeah i see
okay now i gotcha yeah i completely
people do that all the time hey no
pressure it's like hey [ __ ] you we we
barely know each other yeah people
people will do that a lot they do that a
lot because they're trying to soften it
but it's obvious like this is a huge
yeah open it by saying i know this is a
huge ask and i'm very sorry that's how
you preface that yes he doesn't say hey
no pressure
but uh can i borrow twenty five thousand
dollars right right
yeah that's true that's a big move the
no pressure has to be picked
wisely you can't just use a no pr hey no
pressure but uh my wife is dilating
could you deliver it
[Laughter]
yeah i'm with you
no pressure's just
i don't know it no that it bugs me a
little bit it's so obvious that it's
such an obvious play
at least hide it a little hey no
pressure but can you uh do a 12-day
shoot for free for me and uh
and then watch my dog the entire time
right right exactly no i'm with you on
that one i hate the no pressure where
there is pressure
because there is you're lying to me out
of the gate no pressure it's a lie it's
all pressure what uh what's a peep of
yours
i had this last night wrote it down
immediately because i hate this [ __ ]
you ever have the guy who's telling you
something you don't care about already
he's like oh my nephew he uh he got in a
little league and then uh they wouldn't
let him in you know they wouldn't they
wouldn't let the let him in because they
said he wasn't good enough i'm like oh
yeah i don't know you i don't know your
nephew like i don't know you you're
already on to your nephew like first of
all how do we get here and then he's
like let me show you let me show you his
swing and i'm like
i don't want to see the kid swing i
don't give a [ __ ] he's like he's got a
great swing this is on breezy point and
i'm like all right all right
you're not even a sports guy like for me
i'd be like oh look i'm i like baseball
i mean i i humored him i was like sure
let's see the swing yeah i can't imagine
you you don't want confrontation no
oh yeah i'm up against the wall with
this guy he's like oh yeah yeah
and that's another thing when people are
just like coming at you and you're like
i can't get further away from you i'm
literally pressing against the wall and
you you love that but
so he couldn't find on his phone now
he's doing the thing where he's like
hold on hold on up [ __ ] i can't hold it
it's in here somewhere and i'm like
you're struggling to find a thing to
show me that i don't care about anyway
like even if you get it
i don't want to see it the thing we
don't want to do is now an inconvenience
yes exactly
great way to put it so now he's like
hold on hold on and like other people
are talking to me and i'm like oh yeah
and i'm trying to like get out of it and
go go to them but he's like hold on i'm
gonna find it and now he's saying it
like i'm gonna find it like
we got this don't worry i'm not gonna
let you down like no no you're letting
me down by showing me that's the letting
me down i'm already dying here but you
think letting me down is not pulling it
up he's like i got it don't worry and
i'm like i don't want to see it anyway
that should be a socially acceptable
thing to say you're killing me
are killing me right now
we have a infinite uh amount of time
right on earth
and you were you're killing it yes
slowly i and i'm like secretly jealous
because i'm like what world are you
living in where do you think strangers
want to see this nephew swing a bat like
you better not go back to breezy point
with this story i know i feel bad this
guy's never heard of an iphone or a pie
he's pulling this up on a rotary like
this guy is so he was old school they
had bike remember those bike shorts not
bicycle shorts but shorts at the brand
bike they had like a weird waist this
guy was out to lunch he was all over the
road but i'm just saying plugging is
special
he's pulling this thing up but i'm like
i didn't want to see it anyway i'm glad
the phone came pulled up and you're
still trying to show me and he finally
found it and it was a kid going
and i'm like all right how old was that
he's probably 12 13. i mean jesus christ
little league or something i'm like i
don't care anyway and you're struggling
with it and you're making what just
could be the next a-rod
this is the [ __ ] the breezy point the
the breezy point kid ah i saw him wet i
i knew he had it i could tell i couldn't
see anything
i'm like mark you gotta get the breezy
point sensation on we might be drunk
it's a huge get well if he makes it big
we'll have him on and i'll [ __ ] on his
uncle but uh yeah just the the the
four minutes of like i'm gonna get it
don't worry
you get a lot of that in the road too or
like you just kind of want to like sit
in the green like thank god where the
point we can kind of just like sit in
the green room and just be like let me
just [ __ ] shut off for a second yeah
it's necessary you start to get the uh
like seinfeld does tm
and at first you're like look at this
[ __ ] hippie doing the tm jeez he sits
um
you know that whole thing but you're
like i get it now i get the
shutting down and just having a minute
for you and
like kind of re-centering
but i mean i still can't do it do you
meditate no i can't do it either it's
very hard it's like it'll be like things
like notice the smells and i'm like oh
cool uh drunken noodles take out from
earlier i feel so zen
no i'm not good at it i understand that
it's is good for you and that it helps
but i get it but it's very my id is so
bad it's very hard
i i would like i've done it before and
it has helped oh really i think it's
just good to be aware of your breathing
we we are so over worked yeah like we
don't realize it because we like our
jobs but like man we don't take days off
like it's crazy and if i do take a day
off it's like a travel day or something
right right you know it's like it's true
so it's um
that's a good point it is good to be
aware of of your
mind and your body i i think but i'm not
good at it i'm not either but i do see
people like that and i'm like well
that's
he probably knows i mean he's done it he
i i think seinfeld has got a wisdom that
we probably don't have right doing this
that long i remember being on the road
with disease he would do it phil hanley
would do it too they would do it they
would meditate yeah every day twice a
day and they would feel like i would be
pounding coffee at like 5 p.m and they
would be like energized by their own
body and there's something pretty damn
cool about that that's super cool i
asked seinfeld i was like what is with
the tf what's the uh the upside of that
anything you have stanford what's the
deal
ah that's great yeah you're sitting in
the corner you're doing this
god knows what's going on what's the
deal with a dalai lama
he's on a llama
[Laughter]
but
he's he had the best answer
and i was like oh you've gotten asked
this before but he goes you ever get
like a great night's sleep but you just
feel ready for the day
i'm like yeah yeah that's the best but
it's rare and he goes i have that every
time after i
meditate i was like jeez
now i guess i gotta do it
we should do it we should do it let's do
it because the fact you have add and
it's hard for you
imagine if you beat that imagine you got
past that and went to the other side i
feel like that would be
a big deal that'd be a breakthrough yeah
you know like beat the 80d yeah yeah
sure i want to have other thoughts but
i'm pushing back
and i'm going to calm you down you're
not calming me down
i have 80d but i think this is common
with people with add where i am
obsessive with certain things that
there's things that i really am into i
become obsessive like
weird things like
movie facts sure basketball statistics
weird things like that
comedy i can talk all day you know it's
one of those weird things where like but
i do feel it happens a lot of time i'll
be accused of having add and i'm like
it's like midnight and i'm tired and
someone's like you weren't listening to
my to my story about my nephew swing
yeah and i'm like
well maybe that's not on me right right
well yeah some people are just boring as
hell yeah so yeah that's not your fault
but no you're right you're right
can't blame everything on the 80d some
people suck something but i do i do have
it for sure it is hard for me to focus
even like with things occasionally i do
care about yeah
what about these people going atd is not
real you know you know there's all those
guys like anxiety is not a thing oh
that's gonna suck it up that's
completely crazy that's crazy that's
someone who doesn't have anxiety like i
don't have my i get anxiety but i've
seen people with worse anxiety than me
and i'm like oh it's so real clearly
yeah dude i mean don't you ever get
those nights where you're like just
panicking yes there are people that feel
like that all the time
that's that's real anxiety there are
people that are medicated for anxiety
anxiety is [ __ ] real it's real i had
an anxiety attack
i don't want to say i've had them a
bunch but i've had one i had that was
like
oh this is an anxiety attack i'm so bad
at math i failed out of college i got
into community college in baton rouge
louisiana i'm in math class algebra i
cannot do math to save my life if my mom
was my mom's life was dependent on me
doing an algebra problem i couldn't do
it damn and i was sitting at a table
with like eight other kids that'd be a
really weird uh serial killer
the fraction killer
but i'm sorry i'm trying to educate
people
this whole thing i'm trying to help
never used it once by the way yeah
louisiana public school system but i'm
sitting there at community college it's
hot out whatever and i'm sweating over
this test i'm just staring at this test
it's like a final exam if i pass this i
get through the [ __ ] school i'm
praying to god and i remember i was
looking down at it and the test got
blurry and i was dripping sweat and it
was like hitting the pages and i
remember being like oh my god i'm having
an anxiety attack i thought i was gonna
die and i fell backwards in the seat wow
and they let me leave i was like oh i'm
freaking out they let me leave and i
think i got out of it and you walked
away like kaiser so say you just got
away with it
i fixed my limp
and i got it together yeah um but no
that was uh that was one of the worst
anxiety moments of my life and uh
just
went into i changed my majors i went i
mean is that a faint would you call it i
don't think i fainted because i never
went out like mentally but i fell
backwards in the chair because i just
lost it i laid down my body my body
tightened up yeah exactly and uh oh my
god it was like out of a movie like are
you okay the lady's fanning me it's some
southern lady you know and uh this boy's
got the vapors yeah
exactly i said the n-word it got weird
but uh yeah yeah you ever had a reeling
a proper anxiety attack not like that no
i haven't we have a friend who's got bad
anxiety and he got hives before a show
once and he was kind of like
he was turning red and having splotches
and i remember like oh that's what it
was right after he stole mary's shoes
[Laughter]
it was a real attack i was like oh
that's the real deal right there damn
yeah i'll tell you after
i knew it
i was there hell yeah
we're all there i think i know what it
is yeah you probably know what it is i
think i know it but i remember being
like wow this guy is
big red blops on his face yeah that's
rough yeah yeah that's the thing you
don't think about is like people
like there's a lot of rejection and
pressure
in so many careers that like
it's it's crazy it's a weird choice like
this ain't france we [ __ ] we got we
got a long work week here in america oh
yeah we we got high pressure yeah high
blood pressure oh yeah we got weird food
yeah it's it's weird cause you go to
like you ever been to italy or paris or
any of that like they are just chilled
out compared to us yeah cigarettes wine
and all the women are still thin somehow
yeah
the hell is that [ __ ] portions i think
it's portions i think it's portion and
it's fresh but also cigarettes if you're
smoking cigarettes that's probably
killing your appetite too true true also
i think we are like the kings of
snacking oh we can graze because they
like they're known for like croissants
but it's like you know yeah richard
jenny used to have a great bit about how
what we do like we they had the
croissants we made the chris
sandwich like there's nothing more
american you're like oh that's a great
observation another underrated guy
richard jenny check him out classic
classic killer
joke comic great observations great
performer too great performance rare
great writer performer that's true yeah
another guy who killed himself brutal um
from brooklyn
but he was great uh yeah so true they're
thinner than us we're fat as [ __ ]
and my whole family's fat and uh yet
they they eat pasta or or you know
cheesecake and croissants and pizza and
all this [ __ ]
what is that
i think it's preservatives too i think
we're eating a lot of like garbage yeah
funyuns and [ __ ]
yeah they're not eating funyuns over
there
yeah
yeah yeah
pizza rolls
yeah i feel like also the portion
control thing that was like we eat big
portions i eat a lot i really like i eat
a lot man and then i just walk
like my mom cooked this dinner the other
night and i just like my brother and i
were like we go back for seconds like we
eat a lot yeah keep it coming i say we
do dessert i mean we do the french i
think it's just like they eat rich foods
but it's smaller portions yeah they
don't have a buffet mindset like buffet
we literally eat till you can can't eat
anymore it's like it's like a game it's
a game you ever go to a buffet it's
[ __ ] great yeah it's great i love it
i grew up on buffets there are people
i've talked to with like what's lower
quality food i'm like yeah but there's
everything every you want an egg roll
you want salmon you want a chicken
paprikash it's all there general sews
you get a [ __ ] taco you got soft
serve it's incredible oh my god the
jello my god the jello cookies cookies
as far as the eye can see
it's what's your go-to at a buffet i go
i've i've done but i got a phd in
buffets i've done everything oh me too
the key is at a buffet is
you you want to think with your stomach
you go oh my god look at that lasagna
you want to just pile it on but the key
is get a little more lasagna because you
just want to taste it yeah you taste the
lasagna and you cannot you don't over
doing the carbs exactly you want that
sliced turkey in there get the turkey
get the gravy eat half the egg roll a
lot of waste going on and then i pile it
on top i don't care what it is
cheesecake tiramisu lasagna pancakes i
pile the whole thing on top with shrimp
shrimp i get a boiled shrimp and then a
side of uh
some noodles too i will do the chinese
area as well i will do oh yeah they got
sushi at the buffet i'll [ __ ] roll
the dice hell yeah i'll do always i went
to a buffet once with oh it was a shitty
buffet with oysters rockefeller and i
was like i'm a struggling young comic
let's
dance give me the shellfish [ __ ]
oh i'll do crab legs oh hell yeah i put
the bib on i get the lobster i'm
cracking that [ __ ] crab legs [ __ ]
rule oh i love crab leg it's work but
when you get that meat out of there you
feel like a prospector you're like i did
it i found the meat the gold butter
lemon seafood it's like i don't think
there's anything better no no i think
that might be my favorite thing to eat
is like really good seafood
i'm with you i'm with you you can't top
it man there's a new orleanian seafood
like you'd go to the grocery store even
in that window or that that like case
the glass case with just the row of
seafood oh my god it was like it was
glowing like the the
suitcase and pulp fiction
i loved it
uh what what's your go-to for seafood i
mean i'm a crawfish guy which i know i'm
biased but like boyle crawfish the fat
guy like rolls that out on the red yeah
just like your sleeves man yeah yeah
it's the best oh you just pop open you
have a beer next to you your hands are
filthy your mouth is burning whoo
suck the head baby
i've never been a crawfish guy i i mean
[ __ ]
lobster in the house i'm [ __ ] going
crazy i haven't had it for so many years
yeah
um mops are a little overrated i think
but a lobster rolls [ __ ] money
lobster roll is great good call lobster
roll with fries that's a [ __ ] that's
a good meal hot or cold
oh i like it cold i don't like it i like
a hot bun obviously but uh but a cold
cold lobster i love it i love that it's
like borscht you can get hot or cold i
could go you know what i could go hot
though i love boris hot or cold too i'm
[ __ ]
i guess if it's the summer i want a coal
but if it's like indoors i want it hot
yeah borsch is so good because gazpacho
i think is
nobody wants that [ __ ] i like it oh come
on
in the summer a nice veggie soup cold
i'm gonna order that at a restaurant
i'll go borscht ahead of it but i'll
[ __ ] order it all right all right
i'll go borsch ahead of it too not
everyone crushes the gazpacho but when
you have a good gazpacho that's [ __ ]
nice that is nice yeah i love borsch is
my favorite soup that's my number one oh
and the the comedy seller borsch is
top-notch it's great viselka man the
selka too support veselka man i think
they've been struggling this pandemic if
you're in new york city uh east 9th
street or i believe it's 9th street 9th
and 2nd 2nd avenue i mean
24 hours you can't do much better they
got everything but man the pierogies the
borscht
the everything it's just one of the best
yeah i got a hot 4.5 i give it a four
point eight i give it
sorry oh sorry we've had some late
nights in there we've had some meetings
in there we'll meet a vaselka we'll talk
it out we'll figure it out i mean that's
a great what is it a polish look at that
[ __ ] it's ukrainian i believe oh look at
that beautiful oh that [ __ ] stuffed
cabbage with gravy i will [ __ ] eat
that ass why isn't stuffed cabbage
talked about more that is one of the
best dishes on the planet stuffed
cabbage stuffed peppers that meat the
pierogi i mean that's great food fat
grandmas from poland or the ukraine are
it's probably my favorite like this is
probably my favorite like comfort food
yeah you go borscht you look at that
vodka
my mom makes the best lag because about
right oh my god how nice is that to try
one pierogies we should do that with
hanukkah maybe this this december we do
that oh i like it we got all this man
this is i think that's what we do yeah
we we gotta we got we gotta do this one
day i'm down baby look at that i love
patreon or something the jiggly arms on
the lady with the apron pulling that
lock out of the oven with some apple
sauce and sour cream sour cream on that
dude a little [ __ ] sweet onions i
love the uh the mushroom barley there
i'm [ __ ] i'm getting hard dude this
is crazy
that's some sour cream coming out of
here that's thinking about the midwest
you go to these german towns these
polish towns these pollocks can pull out
some cabbage it's unreal and and we
don't really have a lot of it in the
south we didn't have any of that [ __ ]
really i'm so over mac and cheese it's
to me
it's fine it's fine it's fine if you're
doing something crazy with like it's too
like soft when you do the crunch in
there i'm down when there's like the
bread crumbs but like
i don't know if there's a more overrated
food than mac and cheese yeah just
cheese and
shitty pasta it's easy i don't know i i
get it at a barbecue i'll do a scoop
it's look i like it but it's not my
it's not even people like oh man i'm a
mac and cheese remember when when there
was like it was like the earth it was
like probably the early 2000s mid-2000s
yep when people's entire personality was
like i like bacon that's how i feel
about mac and cheese people i'm like
yeah it's cheese and pasta of course you
like but there were people like for a
period was like i like bacon and you're
like wow you like the crispiest saltiest
like who doesn't like bacon man yeah
even vegans look at that [ __ ] and
they're like i wish i could indulge the
taliban likes bacon we get it
what's the the uh they had bacon vodka
for a hot minute that came out bacon had
a run
mac and cheese had a huge run there was
all those places in new york like what
was it called
sneeze or cheese yeah yeah
smack smack that was it which is a
little offensive to the drug addicts by
the way but they walked in very upset
they were like you have misrepresented
yourself what the hell this is worse
than that place called crackle
but yeah yeah is it still open
i think it is i think uh it was pretty
good
you know they had buffalo mac and cheese
that was [ __ ] good that is pretty
good see look you're not gonna get a
thin person in smack even in the ads
they keep it real i appreciate that but
it's just mac and cheese i don't know
expand your pal get a stuffed cabbage
for once in your life
broadening it does look pretty good yeah
i'll if i'm gonna be like bad and
indulge i want like french fries like
you know yeah the worst thing for you by
the way that's so good though i know a
bunch of nutritionists and they all say
french fries don't eat them worse than
chips worse than chips damn it's that
thick potato potato apparently potato is
not great for you it's a starch and i'll
tell that to the irish they were dying
for them
i mean i love potato french fries are
like the best bad food though
and i like the dip of them and they're
just right there and steak and potato is
like the ultimate
american hearty meal steak potato with
like a scotch or a jack and coke or oh
the bar jew works at bobby vans i was
saying on the 100 episode we should go
down there and have a steak should we do
that yeah we'll get a couple of petey
scotches and have a steak and [ __ ] with
each other bobby van is that good
ah
i think it's pretty uh solid you know
solid steakhouse
let's look at the ratings 1969 on park
avenue you can't go wrong let's [ __ ]
do it let's do it or we can go to that
place old homestead or something i think
he works on the one on 50th
50th that's right by here oh beautiful
old homestead he works there no no i'm
just saying that's the oldest i've never
been there oh i went there once it's a
good it's good yeah because whenever we
if you go there you're not buying it's
some rich guy who's like we're going old
homestead you know
so it's uh it's a fun time remember that
when we went to a schumer and a bunch of
other guys bill hanley keane keane's is
the best that is nice talk about old new
year we were talking like yeah they did
you know it's funny they did a billions
episode there where it was like they
ordered the mutton
that was that's the thing that orders as
keynes everyone's like you gotta get the
mud i've never had what is button all i
know is the seinfeld episode thanks for
mutton it's red meat i don't know it's
it's from a cow is it not
i think it's some something to a much
yeah what yeah what what makes a mud in
the mud it's is it goat is it uh
wait a minute wait a minute one refers
to the flesh of the mature ram right or
ew at least one year old sheep
it's a sheep interesting i was totally
wrong i'm sorry 20 months old wow it's
like an epstein they get in early they
get out the meat of the sheep six to 10
days and 10 weeks old is usually sold as
baby lamb and spring lamb
damn
he was on the lamb
yeah he was
damn that is [ __ ] weird so it's oh
mutton i bet it's good it does look good
damn
we can get some keys dude oh man we
probably gotta get a reservation do we i
assume they do outdoor dining too though
i bet there's wrong yeah we could figure
it out damn keane's is [ __ ] legendary
dude what are we at i i feel like we've
gone three days here this two feels
feels like we've been blowing the light
are we okay
oh we gotta do a bit let's do a bit all
right i got nothing i got because my
shit's either working or it's just a i
lose ideas let me try a loose id on you
give me a lucy i was talking to someone
and they told me uh they don't like
movies like one of those people it's
like who are who [ __ ] doesn't like i
was you know i said to them i said you
know who does like movies uh kim jong-un
kim jong-un likes movies and they were
like what does that mean i'm like that
he's a better hang than you ah i would
rather hang out with a north korean
dictator right and then you think about
it and you're like well aside from
murdering people and treating his
country terribly and killing family
members
he's probably fun
oh yeah maybe he's got a flat top he's
young he's in the basketball he loves
movies yeah he knows rodman
that is true i was thinking but like it
is funny when people are like people
people with the dumbest opinions are
like proud of them yes
i'm like i i don't like movies and it's
like
you're proud to not like
i would keep that quiet it's like it's
like yeah you're proud that you don't
like
a thing that's like by the way we've
done as well as anybody
americans oh yeah we got so many good i
mean it's just a weird thing to like
that's the hill you're dying on no i'm
with you and they think it makes it more
interesting when in fact it actually
makes you less fun or less desirable you
don't like movies get out of it you know
that guy like i don't like ice cream i
don't get it [ __ ] you that's what dude
that's it's pushing back in the day was
like i don't even own a television
you're like oh okay don't talk to me
right right it's like literally when
someone's like the rolling stones suck
and you're like yeah they're the problem
not that you were a [ __ ] idiot
exactly contrarian i know the joke is
here it's more i'm just annoyed yeah
that isn't there might not be a bit here
this might be something i just maybe
it's a peeve but it might be a peeve you
know oh i [ __ ] stink no no i i feel
more than a bit
i think the angle is though that they
think they're interesting when in fact
they're actually revealing that they
suck
you know because like the kkk also very
proud
you know they're like hey no we this is
the right thing to do we're burning
crosstalk just cause you're proud
doesn't mean you're right there you go
yeah it's like it's like the proud boys
yeah just cause you're proud doesn't
mean you're right well don't tell that
to the gays
that whole parade would go to hell
like yeah that that's an interesting
angle because they think it'll make me
oh this will make me stand out but
sometimes standing out
it's kind of like when people say i'm
open-minded and you're like yeah but so
is he about [ __ ] kids right he's more
open-minded than you are
in that
yeah thinking it's really that you think
you're interesting for not liking yes
for not liking a thing that
that is just like how do you not like
yeah it's popular you're writing off a
whole
[ __ ] art
yeah
right i don't like movies
and it's okay to not like it but yeah
you should be weird don't act like
you're [ __ ] like you're better than
me yeah yeah like i don't like movies
yeah
yeah you should look inward a little bit
like why don't i like movies i guess i
can't sit there for two hours or have
you seen good movies
yeah there's nothing here [ __ ] go go
to yours i'll i'll think of something
about it i'm i'm playing with it
this is trash
literally my jokes are either that right
now or they're working i don't have a
lot of in-between that need like
tweaking well new ideas are
so few and far between like good new
ideas that movie one's hidden from a
couple weeks ago what's that the one
about uh
how uh
[ __ ]
i i basically
uh
my girlfriend will say um
you know you're trying to have sex with
me and you know we're watching
a movie and i didn't want to do it and
she's like you don't have sex to watch a
movie and i was like i'll [ __ ] you
during the movie that you picked
that's a great joke like i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna [ __ ] you like i don't
wanna [ __ ] doing godfather do i'll
[ __ ] the [ __ ] out of you doing uh little
women ah
you know so the turn is like i have more
confidence in my ability to pick
a movie than i do in my sexual prowess
cause i can say [ __ ] about the movie i
can't say about what i'm doing in bed
like i can't [ __ ] someone and she's not
into it and be like you just didn't get
it
it was ahead of its time that's what i
did so that's hidden yeah what do you
have great reviews well that's that's
when we talked out here what what what
are you guys i like that uh well i'll
come back with something better next
week that was loose same same uh i don't
think i have a big one either but uh me
and my friend were talking about how we
were younger and this is also loose some
of how we were younger that uh
used to hear about ninjas a lot more
like remember it was all like everything
was ninja this ninja that i'm like well
i guess because they're doing better
ninja please yeah
like ninjas they're they're not around
much you don't hear about them much
you're like yeah because they're killing
it they're that quiet
you know and i think that's a funny
twist but i'm like what's the what's the
point here i'm making yeah
that's who that's how you know they're
doing well when you never hear from them
yes
exactly kind of like a deadbeat dad
right
right
you know they're killing it if they're
just not around right or a politician
like the more you hear about a
politician that means there was a
scandal or they [ __ ] up or there's
something happened but like
what's another what's another job you
don't want to hear [ __ ] from
cia fbi they're kind of qualified for
api's good yeah
you want them to be uh hush-hush
you keep hearing buzzing about the the
fbi maybe they're not so an intern if
you hear a lot about an intern that
means she sucked off the president
uh it could have been a throwaway that's
a thing
what's another job that you if you hear
about
alan havey had that great joke he's like
my wife my ex-wife was in the cia was
great she'd come home like how was your
day honestly i can't talk but he's like
perfect
that's a great joke that's a great joke
but uh
yeah the the ninja thing it might have
just been nothing how about let me throw
this one at you that feels like a
throwaway line i'll get off
maybe like i'll i'll tack that on to a
bit you know sure sure doesn't feel like
a full
premise
okay sorry my my tile is going nuts why
is your towel going i don't know i think
i'm sitting on it wrong
but
jesus tile shut up
all right all right it's done
the uh
i'm doing this whole bit about how this
slut-shaming
like you shouldn't [ __ ] shame but i
think women hate [ __ ]
so there's all this like
anti-slut-shaming stuff but like ladies
you hate them like women will be like i
hate that [ __ ] [ __ ] that [ __ ]
so you're like so it is bad
so you gotta tell us
because this is on you guys you know
women are like how come if a man sleeps
a lot of girls he's a player but if a
girl sleeps a lot of guys she's a [ __ ]
and i'm like well i think because you
believe that ladies and that gets a big
laugh and then i'm like
you guys
hate [ __ ] men we love [ __ ] and that
kills but i think i need something some
more there
yeah
the only time a man hates a [ __ ] is if
he's dating one right right that's the
only time a man hates a [ __ ] is if he
catches his wife [ __ ] the neighbors
like you [ __ ] yes no wife is like having
his ass eaten by his wife and is like
you [ __ ]
yeah yeah i mean and then they'll be
like well men call women [ __ ] too and
i'm like yeah we do it because it works
it still gets a rise out of you but if
you call me a [ __ ] i'm like let's party
yeah yeah we don't care you guys care
internally yeah it's in you ladies you
act like it's this man thing like these
[ __ ] men are these toxic men are yelling
at [ __ ] like
yeah but you have the problem with it it
bothers you yeah
jim jeffries different bit but jim
jefferies have a bit of i thought it was
so funny about he's like to be to be a
stud you know you have to be rich you
have to be good looking you like to be a
[ __ ] you just have to be there like
there are there are dwarf [ __ ]
there are no dwarf stars i mean he was
maybe in their own community but none of
them crossed over that was right jim
jeffries but i thought was so good well
yeah bill burr had the bit he's like why
is the girl a [ __ ] and a guy a stud and
she's like because it's being a stud is
hard it takes work you gotta like win a
woman over being a [ __ ] is easy that's
why it's a knock
but my whole point is women act like
it's this thing that guys say like these
[ __ ] but it's like yeah but you hate
them too yeah
it's just us well they're [ __ ] [ __ ]
up for them
cause they they all have like a product
so to speak and one group is giving it
away for easy so if you're a [ __ ]
five-star restaurant you don't like
wendy's
that's great yeah that's the angle
there's the angle all right we got it
it's kind of like like blm black we're
like hey black lives matter
but it would be like if black people
also hated black people no no you guys
are fighting for black people and you
still like black people they're like if
there was samuel jackson and jango as
part of that group you're like you can't
be part of us right right exactly it
doesn't make sense
so
there you go ladies
that's a good bit now that's hot we got
uh good stuff coming out uh also [ __ ]
man please watch my doc which is now i
would assume out uh youtube.com
sam morrell m-o-r-r-i-l or just youtube
uh full capacity samurail on youtube
gonna be a banger lover we have here i'm
fighting with salacuse like crazy lately
so it better be good better be worth uh
[ __ ] up our friendship no
this is how art is created passion
world's colliding please watch that see
me at uh millersville oh no atlanta this
weekend then millersville
oh no i believe it's millersville this
weekend this is in two weeks right yeah
so millersville pennsylvania
uh
915. then we got um
[ __ ] we got philly helium
one of my faves 16 through the 19th moon
tower in austin for a few nights that'll
be great a lot of great comics there uh
i'll be in st louis
indianapolis springfield missouri
chicago
uh [ __ ]
comedy works in denver phoenix
samuel.com
shows
i'll see you on the road i can't wait
hell yeah i'll be on the road as well
nashville
uh west palm beach
atlanta uh
madison wisconsin
all kinds of fun gigs
checkmarknormancomedy.com
uh
yeah watch our specials give us a like
give us a comment we'll get our albums
they're all out there folks netflix is
out give that a fun hello and uh yeah
hopefully we get that whiskey at some
point who knows
we're working on it lawyers yeah it's
all the legal mumbo jumbo who the hell
knows but uh yeah keep keep watching
keep drinking get on the patreon
subscribe to the youtube channel
obviously leave a nice review subscribe
to that patreon as mark said patreon.com
we might be drunk pod
thanks guys we love you
comedy
[Music]
you